while Khloe Kardashian gets closer and
closer to her due date cardi B's baby
bump makes her debut plus her money
keeps it real about the fifth harmony
breakup hello everyone the countdown to
Beyonce at Coachella is officially on I
will be there this week and bring you
guys up close to all the action at the
Music Festival and I cannot wait I got
my hair laid I'm ready to go in the
meantime though we're on baby watch over
here Khloe Kardashian is about ready to
pop any minute now and we know she's set
to give birth in Cleveland but one sign
that close little girl with Tristan
Thompson has not yet arrived well we
were with grandma Kris Jenner just last
night as she hit up the fashion Los
Angeles Awards okay so I said if Kris
comes tonight we don't have a baby yet
so you came so we're waiting stuff yeah
no no baby yet no and you're correct how
is everything going
how would the bratty Mary sing I said I
saw you on the list I wrote my questions
and I said if she comes we're not at the
hospital now there you go
are you ready do you feel ready or you
excited this little world is she ready
you know she's ready because I think so
so we'll see she's diving a little bit
huh you give her advice I give her so
much advice she's sick of me yeah we all
give her advice because you know most of
us have had a child or two in this
family so yeah we're just I mean when
you have your first baby you're scared
yeah today Chloe posted this shot from
March and the caption we are ready
whenever you are little mama
as I mentioned Chloe's expected to give
birth in Cleveland she appears to be
there tonight but her basketball player
man
just food in New York for tonight's
Cavaliers vs. Knicks game so for now the
whole family is just waiting and so are
we
meanwhile the wait is over for cardi B
who finally showed off her baby bump the
25 year old rapper hit in New York today
just hours after officially confirming
on SNL that a up she is pregnant with
her first child
[Music]
check out cardi coming out like Beyonce
confirming her pregnancy on national TV
let's hope she doesn't a pull-up Queen B
and pull out of Coachella though she's
expected to be there this weekend as
well and I'm tripping out already seen
her spit some fire will also like
walking around the Coachella stage but
we're down to see that cute little bump
cardi but I got a question guys did
cardies little sis Tennessee
accidentally reveal the baby's sex the
proud sister took to Instagram with a
heartfelt post and while the caption now
reads I'm going to be able to hold your
baby and give the baby all the kisses
and hugs screenshots show Hennessy
originally wrote give her all the kisses
and hugs so is currently having a baby
girl the time will tell but it goes
without saying that all eyes are on
cardi B these days and her pal Jimmy
Fallon was also watching her SNL
performance this week Fallon Robins
cardi as his co-host on this night show
we're so excited for you to have cardi B
as your co-host how stoked are you I
mean it's gonna be so exciting okay I
mean that song saying I was like I was
hoping and I knew it and she's just
she's the best and it's a great album
it's one of the best of the year you
know that's been to be some more TV
magic after the first wild interview in
December went viral good all right now
something else that shook the internet
was that fifth harmony split eighties
tonight got her monitor really opened up
about the group's decision behind that
hiatus and why it was the toughest
statement how was it making that
announcement to the fans like
heartbreaking scary very scary and
heartbreak for me personally like the
first day that we even put out the
announcement for the hiatus it was the
toughest day so many people saying oh my
god what happened like what's wrong and
just having that attention on something
that you already know is real and the
fact that everybody else knows it's real
it's like wow this is really happening
and it's definitely gonna be an
adjustment it's all I've known for the
last six years but I'm excited was there
something like is there a drama we don't
know about that cause this breakup like
do you want to clear the air is it I
have no air no air to clear but no
there's no area clear it's an
understanding that we have amongst each
other it's it's literally been six years
you know and I feel like we we owe that
to each other and we owe it to ourselves
to figure out who am I now far down the
road like 15 20 years from now would you
guys gets together again and do
something big in the future I'm all in
you're in I'm in she's in Harmonizers
but Nirvana also told us she's in the
studio so trying to figure out her own
sound but that she's grateful to finally
fully be herself get more with naman and
Armani up on our site ET online.com but
that's it for now kids thanks for
watching and give this video a little
like I'll see you guys